This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Greeley, Colorado is a mid-sized city out in the eastern plains of the state. The landscape is simple and flat. Cow pastures stretch as far as the eye can see, and most days, the breeze smells of manure. Greeley is a meatpacking town. The world's largest meat processor, JBS, has its U.S. headquarters there, and many people in the town work for the company. When most Americans imagine a place like Greeley,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。格里利是科罗拉多州东部平原上的一座中型城市。这里的地貌平坦而简单。牛群牧场一眼望不到边，大多数时候，微风中都弥漫着粪便的味道。格里利是一座肉类加工城。全球最大的肉类加工商JBS的美国总部就设在这里，镇上许多人都为该公司工作。当大多数美国人想象格里利这样的地方时，
they think of cowboys, farmers, political conservatives, and mostly white people. That's reporter Esther Honig. That was my assumption about Greeley, at least until I worked there as an agricultural reporter. That's when I realized the city is actually incredibly diverse. Test, test. A few years ago, I went to interview a man we'll call Muhammad.
他们会想到牛仔、农民、政治保守派，以及大多数白人。那是记者埃丝特·霍尼格。至少在我作为农业记者在那里工作之前，我对格里利的印象就是这样。那时我才意识到，这座城市实际上非常多元。测试，测试。几年前，我去采访了一位我们姑且称之为穆罕默德的男士。
Hello. He lived in a small, single-story house in a quiet neighborhood on the northeast side of town. How old are you? Daddy, cheers. Okay. Muhammad spoke Rohingya in only a little English, so we used a translator to communicate. At an old for Micah dinner table, Mohammed served me coffee. He wore a long skirt that's customary in his home country of Burma, and he told me what life was like there.
你好。他住在这座城市东北部一个安静社区里的一栋小型平房里。你多大了？爸爸，干杯。好的。穆罕默德只会说一点点英语，所以我们用翻译来交流。在餐桌旁，穆罕默德为我端上了咖啡。他穿着他家乡缅甸习俗中的长裙，并告诉我那里的生活是什么样的。
So he's talking about the paddy, the rice. So he plow the land and then he pull in the seedlings, then he transplanted. Mohamed was a rice farmer. But then he faced persecution by the government and had to flee his country. He was registered as a refugee by the UN. And eventually, after undergoing a rigorous background check, he was one of the lucky ones selected for resettlement. I was always thinking how America would be and what I will do there.
所以他在谈论稻田，水稻。他耕地，然后拔秧，再进行移栽。穆罕默德曾是一名稻农。但后来他遭到了政府的迫害，不得不逃离自己的国家。他被联合国登记为难民。最终，在经历了严格的背景调查后，他成为了幸运被选中重新安置的人之一。我一直在想美国会是什么样，我在那里会做什么。
And I was exciting, especially. In 2015, Mohammed left the refugee camp where he'd been living and flew across the world, ending up here in Greeley. This would be his new home. So when I get in America, then my caseworker, within one month, I got the job in JBS. JBS. the massive meat-packing plant in Greeley that we mentioned earlier. To get his job, Muhammad didn't have to speak English. He didn't need any prior experience.
而且我特别兴奋。2015年，穆罕默德离开了他一直居住的难民营，飞越半个地球，最终来到了格里利。这将是他的新家。所以当我到达美国后，我的个案工作者在一个月内就帮我在JBS找到了工作。JBS，就是我们之前提到的格里利那家大型肉类加工厂。为了得到这份工作，穆罕默德不需要会说英语。他不需要任何先前的经验。
The caseworker didn't even really explain what JBS was. He only said JBS there's a many different kind of job. Then you will do one of them. He said just like this. So he didn't tell him that it was a slaughterhouse or that he would be working with meat? He didn't know that? And he didn't know that.
个案工作者甚至没有真正解释JBS是什么。他只说JBS有很多种不同的工作。然后你会做其中一种。他就是这么说的。所以他没告诉他那是一家屠宰场，或者他将要处理肉类？他不知道吗？他确实不知道。
After his first week at JBS, Mohamed realized just what kind of work he'd be doing. He used a large electric knife to remove the skin from cow legs. It was bloody, exhausting labor. In most plants, workers assemble things like cars. But in a meatpacking plant, the workers disassemble animals. They stand along conveyor belts where line speeds run incredibly fast. Up to 450 cows are killed every hour,
在JBS工作的第一周后，穆罕默德意识到他到底在做什么样的工作。他用一把大型电动刀从牛腿上剥皮。那是血腥且令人筋疲力尽的劳动。在大多数工厂里，工人们组装汽车之类的东西。但在肉类加工厂，工人们拆解动物。他们站在传送带旁，流水线速度快得惊人。每小时有多达450头牛被屠宰，
and the workers used wickedly sharp electric knives to break them down into cuts of meat like chalk and rib. And as conveyor belts, meat grinders, and saws rumbled around Muhammad, he looked around the factory floor and noticed something else. Many of the other workers were from places like Somalia, Eritrea, and the Democratic Republic of Congo. They all arrived here as refugees, like him. I understand that people are getting their job
工人们使用极其锋利的电动刀将它们分解成肉块，比如牛腱和肋排。当传送带、绞肉机和锯子在穆罕默德周围轰鸣时，他环顾工厂车间，注意到了另一件事。许多其他工人来自索马里、厄立特里亚和刚果民主共和国等地。他们都像他一样作为难民来到这里。我明白人们在找工作，
as I did. As I did, there's a caseworker. Caseworker, my brother. So he knew that that was, everyone was getting the job the same way. The same way, yeah. The scale of meatpacking in this country is staggering. Half a million people work in the industry,
就像我一样。就像我一样，有个案工作者。个案工作者，我的兄弟。所以他知道，每个人都是通过同样的方式找到工作的。同样的方式，是的。这个国家的肉类加工规模令人震惊。有五十万人从事这个行业，
producing tens of billions of pounds of meat every year and generating billions of dollars in profits. Companies like JBS are among the largest employers in rural America. But the industry doesn't just process animals. It churns through people. The work is so brutal and physically punishing that many don't last long on the job. Workers often suffer chronic injuries from the repetitive nature of the work. They can also lose fingers, even whole appendages. Research shows that there are about two amputations a week across the entire industry, which means that meatpacking companies are always searching for new bodies to run the line.
每年生产数百亿磅的肉类，并创造数十亿美元的利润。像JBS这样的公司是美国农村地区最大的雇主之一。但这个行业不仅仅是加工动物。它还在消耗人。这项工作非常残酷且对身体伤害极大，以至于许多人无法长期坚持。工人们经常因工作的重复性而遭受慢性损伤。他们还可能失去手指，甚至整个肢体。研究表明，整个行业平均每周发生约两起截肢事故，这意味着肉类加工公司一直在寻找新的劳动力来维持生产线运转。
But in the last 20 years, companies like JBS have come to rely on a new source of labor, refugees, arriving through humanitarian programs that are supposed to offer safety and a shot at the American dream. And it's through this particular arrangement that rural Midwestern towns like Greeley have become home to thousands of people like Muhammad, men and women who fled violence and persecution, only to find themselves doing what has long been one of the most dangerous jobs in America. In 1904, the journalist Upton Sinclair went undercover working in meatpacking plants in Chicago. Then he wrote a novel based on his experiences called The Jungle.
但在过去20年里，像JBS这样的公司开始依赖一种新的劳动力来源——通过人道主义项目抵达的难民，这些项目本应提供安全和实现美国梦的机会。正是通过这种特殊的安排，像格里利这样的中西部农村城镇成为了成千上万像穆罕默德这样的人的家园，这些男人和女人逃离了暴力和迫害，却发现自己从事着美国长期以来最危险的工作之一。1904年，记者厄普顿·辛克莱潜入芝加哥的肉类加工厂工作。随后，他根据自己的经历写了一部名为《屠场》的小说。
He described poor, newly arrived immigrants mostly from Eastern Europe who worked in dangerous, squalid conditions. These immigrants came to America chasing the promise of a better life. Instead, they found themselves teetering on the edge of poverty and hunger and facing working conditions even worse than to date. The work left their hands so mingled that their fingernails wore off, and they were exposed to deadly infections. They'd pour acid on sheep pelts and yank out the wool with their bare hands scalding their skin. With the slip of a sharp knife, many workers had severed the tendance of their thumbs. But it wasn't those brutal conditions that captured the public's outrage. As Sinclair later said, quote, I aimed at the public's heart and by accident I hit it in the stomach.
他描述了主要来自东欧的贫穷、新移民在危险、肮脏的环境中工作。这些移民怀揣着美好生活的承诺来到美国。相反，他们发现自己徘徊在贫困和饥饿的边缘，面临着比今天更糟糕的工作条件。工作使他们的双手伤痕累累，指甲脱落，并暴露在致命的感染中。他们把酸液倒在羊皮上，用赤手拔掉羊毛，烫伤了皮肤。随着锋利的刀子滑落，许多工人的拇指肌腱被切断。但引起公众愤怒的并不是这些残酷的条件。正如辛克莱后来所说，引用：“我瞄准了公众的心，却意外地击中了他们的胃。”
End quote. People cared less about exploited workers than about it. about what was ending up on their plates. Sinclair described poisoned rats ground into sausage, or how cows covered in oozing boils were butchered and made into canned meat. Those were the images people couldn't forget. Even if Sinclair's book didn't do exactly what he wanted it to,
引用结束。人们对被剥削的工人关注较少，而更多关注的是……关注他们盘子里最终会出现什么。辛克莱描述了被绞进香肠里的毒死的老鼠，或者长满脓包的牛是如何被屠宰并制成罐装肉的。这些是人们无法忘记的画面。即使辛克莱的书没有完全达到他想要的效果，
it was still influential. Federal laws were enacted to enforce inspections and sanitation. But in the 1940s, it seemed like things were finally going to change for the workers. A boom in the post-war economy meant that people were eating more meat, which in turn increased the hiring at meatpacking plants. Workers' jobs became skilled labor and were unionized. For the first time, their positions were salaried. Meatpackers could finally afford a middle-class lifestyle. They had boats in their driveways and pools in their backyards.
它仍然具有影响力。联邦法律被颁布以强制执行检查和卫生标准。但在20世纪40年代，工人们的情况似乎终于要改变了。战后经济的繁荣意味着人们吃更多的肉，这反过来增加了肉类加工厂的招聘。工人的工作变成了技术劳动，并加入了工会。这是他们第一次有了固定薪水。肉类加工工人终于负担得起中产阶级的生活方式。他们的车道上有船，后院里有游泳池。
But the relief was short-lived because meatpacking companies made a decision that would transform the entire workforce and add a whole new labor. layer of vulnerability in an already dangerous industry. In the 1960s, meatpacking companies left the cities where they've been based for decades and moved their plans to rural America. The shift put them closer to livestock and cut down on transportation costs. Critically, it also let them escape the unions in the cities and the prying eyes of pesky reporters and politicians. But there was a problem. Rural communities that they relocated to did not have sufficient labor for them. This is Donstool, a professor emeritus of anthropology at the University of Kansas.
但这种宽慰是短暂的，因为肉类加工公司做出了一个将改变整个劳动力结构，并在一个本已危险的行业中增加一层全新脆弱性的决定。20世纪60年代，肉类加工公司离开了它们扎根数十年的城市，将工厂搬到了美国农村。这一转变使它们更接近牲畜，并降低了运输成本。至关重要的是，这也让它们摆脱了城市里的工会，以及讨厌的记者和政客的窥探。但有一个问题。它们搬迁到的农村社区没有足够的劳动力。这是堪萨斯大学人类学名誉教授唐·斯图尔。
He told me that without the unions, the working conditions and pay inside the plants declined once again. And to attract the workers they needed, companies looked south to Mexico. Well, meatpacking companies had always advertised on radio stations in South Texas and elsewhere, which broadcast into Mexico, that there were jobs available in meatpacking plants. But in the 1980s, with the blessing of the INS, they were actually set up recruiting stations in Mexico City. There were many reasons that these Latin American workers were drawn to meatpacking, despite its gruesome reputation.
他告诉我，没有了工会，工厂内部的工作条件和工资再次下降。为了吸引所需的工人，公司将目光投向了南方的墨西哥。嗯，肉类加工公司一直都在南得克萨斯州和其他地方的广播电台做广告，这些电台向墨西哥广播，称肉类加工厂有工作机会。但在20世纪80年代，在移民局（INS）的默许下，它们实际上在墨西哥城设立了招聘站。尽管名声不佳，但这些拉丁美洲工人被肉类加工吸引的原因有很多。
One of the attractions of meatpacking for immigrants is that you don't have to speak English to work in a meatpacking plant, and you don't have to have any pre-existing job skills. By the 1960s, Greeley was becoming a little. leader in meatpacking. It was one of the first small towns to build a big modern packing plant, and ranchers from all around came there to harvest their cattle. Increasingly, Mexican immigrants staffed the factory. Many of them had previously worked in nearby agriculture, but these packing jobs were inside, shielded from the hot sun, and they paid better than field work.
肉类加工对移民的吸引力之一是，你在肉类加工厂工作不需要会说英语，也不需要任何预先存在的工作技能。到20世纪60年代，格里利正在成为肉类加工业的领导者。它是最早建立大型现代化包装厂的小城镇之一，来自各地的牧场主都到那里出售他们的牛。墨西哥移民越来越多地充实了工厂。他们中的许多人以前从事附近的农业工作，但这些包装工作是在室内，免受烈日暴晒，而且工资比田间工作更高。
In the 1980s and 90s, new waves of workers arrived in Greeley, not just from Mexico, but other parts of Central America. They moved into the neighborhoods around the packing plant, which was now called Swifton Company. By the early 2000s, about one-third of Greeley's population was Latino. You could see it everywhere. The local grocery stores started selling fresh tortillas and dried chilis imported from Mexico. The schools created ESL courses. But the change also brought backlash.
在20世纪80年代和90年代，新一波工人抵达格里利，不仅来自墨西哥，还来自中美洲的其他地区。他们搬进了包装厂周围的社区，当时该厂被称为斯威夫特公司。到21世纪初，格里利约三分之一的人口是拉丁裔。你随处可见。当地杂货店开始销售从墨西哥进口的新鲜玉米饼和干辣椒。学校开设了英语作为第二语言（ESL）课程。但这种变化也带来了反弹。
The city was starkly divided along racial lines. And meanwhile, in the background, another labor problem was brewing. It was an open secret that hundreds of workers at the plight. plant were undocumented. The meatpacking company reviewed their workers' documentation with a federal system called E-Verify, which was known to be deeply flawed. And on the morning of December 12, 2006, the situation reached a breaking point. That morning, Greeley's meatpackers started the day, like most other days. The first shift arrived at the factory before sunrise. They put on their hard hats and white smocks and took their positions along the massive conveyor belt,
这座城市在种族界线上截然分开。与此同时，在背景中，另一个劳动力问题正在酝酿。工厂里有数百名工人是无证移民，这是一个公开的秘密。肉类加工公司使用一个名为E-Verify的联邦系统审查工人的证件，该系统被认为存在严重缺陷。2006年12月12日早晨，局势达到了临界点。那天早上，格里利的肉类加工工人像往常一样开始了新的一天。第一班工人在日出前到达工厂。他们戴上安全帽，穿上白色工作服，在巨大的传送带旁就位，
ready for the first slaughter of the day. But then, just before the giant factory rumbled to life, all hell broke loose. Just after dawn, federal agents from ICE, immigration and customs enforcement, descended on plants run by Swift and Company, the nation's third largest meatpacker. It's the largest ever crackdown on illegal immigration in the workplace. 1,200 arrests now reported across six states. Shortly after 7 a.m., agents from immigration and customs enforcement charged inside. and swarm the factory floor. People ran like mad.
准备迎接当天的第一次屠宰。但就在巨大的工厂轰鸣启动之前，一切都乱套了。黎明刚过，来自移民及海关执法局（ICE）的联邦特工突袭了由全国第三大肉类加工商斯威夫特公司运营的工厂。这是有史以来针对工作场所非法移民的最大规模打击行动。据报道，六个州共有1200人被捕。上午7点刚过，移民及海关执法局的特工冲进工厂，蜂拥进入车间。人们疯狂逃窜。
Some tried to hide in the cattle pens or inside the bathrooms or supply closets. But in the end, hundreds were rounded up and arrested. Several hundred family members gathered along the fence between the Swift Company and Highway 85. Some were crying. Some were praying. Others were yelling at the federal agents.
有些人试图躲在牛栏里，或者躲在浴室或储藏室里。但最终，数百人被围捕并逮捕。数百名家庭成员聚集在斯威夫特公司和85号公路之间的围栏旁。有些人哭了。有些人正在祈祷。其他人则对联邦特工大喊大叫。
On the scene today, there was no word. Similar scenes, played out in six different meat-packing plants across Middle America. At the same time, on the same day, ICE agents arrested close to 1,300 workers for having, quote, questionable documentation. Overnight, Swift lost about 10% of its workforce. Without enough people, some factories could not operate, and the company was hemorrhaging money. It was a crisis of epic proportions, and it raised the same old question. Where on earth would Swift find more people willing to perform this day?
今天在现场，没有消息。类似的场景在全美中部的六家不同肉类加工厂上演。在同一天、同一时间，ICE特工逮捕了近1300名工人，理由是他们持有“可疑证件”。一夜之间，斯威夫特失去了约10%的劳动力。由于人手不足，一些工厂无法运营，公司损失惨重。这是一场史诗级的危机，它提出了那个老问题：斯威夫特到底去哪里寻找更多愿意从事这种工作的人？
dangerous work. This time Swift found its answer in an unlikely place. A federal program meant to help people fleeing war and persecution. That's when we return. Before the raids in 2006, Swift and Company was already limping along financially. For years, they'd struggled to make a profit and that only got worse when they lost a large, fraction of their workforce. Five months after the rates, it was announced the company was being sold to JBS, the Brazilian-owned meatpacker. The new owners got busy trying to solve the labor problem.
危险的工作。这一次，斯威夫特在一个意想不到的地方找到了答案。一个旨在帮助逃离战争和迫害的人的联邦项目。这就是我们回来后要讲的内容。在2006年的突袭之前，斯威夫特公司在财务上就已经步履蹒跚。多年来，他们一直在努力盈利，而当他们失去很大一部分劳动力时，情况变得更糟了。突袭发生五个月后，该公司宣布被巴西拥有的肉类加工商JBS收购。新东家开始忙于解决劳动力问题。
One news article from that time reported how company officials met in a war room with maps pinned to the walls. They marked the cities and towns outside their meatpacking plants as potential recruitment zones. They advertised the open positions on the radio, newspapers, and billboards. But not many people wanted to sign up. And so, to dig themselves out of this labor shortage, JBS adopted a new strategy. The company set its sights on a new population. Like the undocumented workers before them, these workers didn't speak much English.
当时的一篇新闻文章报道了公司高管如何在作战室里开会，墙上贴着地图。他们将肉类加工厂外的城镇标记为潜在的招聘区。他们在广播、报纸和广告牌上宣传空缺职位。但没多少人愿意报名。因此，为了摆脱这种劳动力短缺，JBS采取了新策略。公司将目光投向了一个新群体。像之前的无证工人一样，这些工人英语说得不多。
They were eager to find jobs and willing to do hard labor that many others refused. And crucially, they were in the country legally. JBS turned to refugees. An aggressive recruitment campaign began. Company representatives went to Denver and staked out East African restaurants and mosques. They offered new hires a cash bonus of up to $1,500 and more for referrals. And they used these same tactics across the heartland, convincing refugees to move away from the cities where they had access to federally funded support services.
他们渴望找到工作，并愿意从事许多其他人拒绝的艰苦劳动。至关重要的是，他们是合法入境的。JBS转向了难民。一场激进的招聘运动开始了。公司代表前往丹佛，在东非餐馆和清真寺蹲点。他们为新员工提供高达1500美元的现金奖励，并为推荐人提供更多奖励。他们在整个美国腹地采取了同样的策略，说服难民搬离那些他们可以获得联邦资助支持服务的城市。
They chartered buses and drove hundreds of refugees to isolated meatpacking towns like Cactus, Texas, Grand Island, Nebraska, and Greeley, Colorado. At the time of the Swift raids, right, everything changed in 2006. Paul Stein was Colorado's refugee coordinator at the time, the most senior person at the state level, and he started to notice more and more refugees moving to Greeley. They were recruited by Swift, vigorously recruited. You had a lot of, at that point, primarily Somalis, some Burmese, who moved in to take advantage of the employment opportunities,
他们包租巴士，将数百名难民运送到像得克萨斯州仙人掌镇、内布拉斯加州格兰德岛和科罗拉多州格里利这样偏远的肉类加工城镇。在斯威夫特突袭时，对吧，2006年一切都变了。保罗·斯坦当时是科罗拉多州的难民协调员，是州一级职位最高的人，他开始注意到越来越多的难民搬到格里利。他们被斯威夫特招募，大力招募。当时你有很多主要是索马里人，还有一些缅甸人，他们搬来利用就业机会，
and then those refugees would petition and bring their families. According to Stein, as well as several other people I interviewed for the story, the number of refugees living in Greeley ballooned overnight. This is a story of backing into a plan rather than having the plan. It totally started because of meatpacking. But when refugees live, landed in Greeley, they struggled with everything. Most of the services Greeley had developed over the years were tailored to Spanish speakers,
然后这些难民会申请并把他们的家人接过来。据斯坦以及我为这个故事采访的其他几个人说，住在格里利的难民人数一夜之间激增。这是一个在没有计划的情况下被迫制定计划的故事。这完全是因为肉类加工业才开始的。但当难民抵达格里利时，他们在各方面都挣扎。格里利多年来发展的大多数服务都是为讲西班牙语的人量身定制的，
not speakers of Rohingya, Somali, or Tigray. Housing was hard to find, and without translation services, families struggled to enroll their kids in school or see a doctor. Soon, an office for refugee resettlement opened up. We started with a very limited presence. I think we had a mighty team of one, one case manager, who for a time actually, worked out of his vehicle. This is James Horan, the president and CEO of Lutheran Family Services, Rocky Mountains,
而不是讲罗兴亚语、索马里语或提格雷语的人。住房很难找，而且没有翻译服务，家庭在为孩子办理入学或看医生时都很困难。不久，一个难民安置办公室开张了。我们最初的规模非常有限。我想我们有一个强大的团队，只有一个人，一名个案经理，他有一段时间实际上是在他的车里办公。这是路德会家庭服务中心落基山分部的总裁兼首席执行官詹姆斯·霍兰，
which ran the office. I think, you know, there really wasn't an infrastructure for other than Spanish-speaking newcomers, right? And so I think a lot of it was just as simple as making the adjustment of new languages, new cultures, and everything that came along with that. Gradually, you could see another wave of change washing over a Greeley. Once again, driven by the meatpacking plant. For decades, the town had been mostly white.
该中心负责运营这个办公室。我想，你知道，除了讲西班牙语的新移民外，真的没有其他基础设施，对吧？所以我认为很多事情就像适应新语言、新文化以及随之而来的一切一样简单。渐渐地，你可以看到另一波变革浪潮席卷格里利。再次由肉类加工厂驱动。几十年来，这个镇主要是白人。
Then it became white and Latino. Now it was increasingly international. On the main boulevard, there was the Mexican grocery store, but you might also see women walking by in a bias. Eventually, a halal market, and an East African restaurant opened up downtown. And the population of refugees continued to grow. Not long after JBS bought Swift, they announced a second shift, meaning the plant would operate more than 18 hours a day and they'd have to double their workforce.
然后它变成了白人和拉丁裔。现在它越来越国际化。在主干道上，有墨西哥杂货店，但你可能还会看到妇女穿着长袍走过。最终，一家清真市场和一家东非餐馆在市中心开业。难民人口持续增长。在JBS收购斯威夫特后不久，他们宣布增加第二班次，这意味着工厂每天将运营超过18小时，他们必须将劳动力增加一倍。
Lucky for JBS, America's refugee resettlement program became a steady source of workers. When I first noticed how this had happened, I was shocked. A program meant to be humanitarian in practice was pushing people into some of the hardest, most dangerous jobs in the country. But as I dug deeper, I learned this wasn't part of a grand malicious scheme. The meatpacking companies were just taking advantage of America's flawed resettlement system and how it was designed to work. America's current refugee system first emerged in the aftermath of the Vietnam War with the Refugee Act of 1980. It increased the number
幸运的是，美国的难民安置项目成为了稳定的工人来源。当我第一次注意到这是如何发生时，我感到震惊。一个本应是人道主义的项目，实际上却在把人们推向这个国家最艰苦、最危险的工作岗位。但随着我深入挖掘，我了解到这并不是一个宏大的恶意阴谋的一部分。肉类加工公司只是在利用美国有缺陷的安置系统及其设计运作方式。美国目前的难民系统最早出现在越南战争结束后，即1980年的《难民法》。它增加了每年
of refugees admitted each year into the country. And for the first time, it created a standardized resettlement process overseen by the federal government. New system, helped to resettle the hundreds of thousands of refugees arriving from Vietnam, Laos, and Cambodia. Asian refugees. They could be called the new settlers of the United States, and they come to America's shores out of desperation, sadness, violence, and deprivation from their own battered homeland.
获准进入该国的难民人数。并且它首次创建了一个由联邦政府监督的标准化安置流程。新系统帮助安置了从越南、老挝和柬埔寨抵达的数十万难民。亚洲难民。他们可以被称为美国的新定居者，他们出于绝望、悲伤、暴力和对自己饱受蹂躏的家园的匮乏而来到美国的海岸。
Many have escaped by small boats from the new communist governments. Often they've braved dangerous seas in small boats, attacks by pirates, and months of overcrowded conditions in refugee camps. They're part of the 300... The resettlement program was well-intentioned, a way to welcome people and offer them a shot at the American dream. But it carried a built-in flaw, rooted in another American impulse.
许多人乘坐小船从新的共产主义政府统治下逃离。他们经常冒着危险，乘坐小船穿越危险的海域，遭受海盗袭击，并在难民营中度过拥挤不堪的数月。他们是那30万……安置项目是出于好意，是一种欢迎人们并为他们提供实现美国梦机会的方式。但它带有一个内在的缺陷，植根于另一种美国冲动。
We wanted them to lift themselves up by their bootstraps. That's why the very first priority of the 1980s Refugee Act was economic self-sufficiency. Refugees were expected to find work and get off-government support as quickly as possible. job counseling is a key part of the orientation effort. Job skills previously learned are sometimes adaptable. In other cases, however, entirely new jobs must be learned and training programs must be set up. In the 45 years since the passage of the Refugee Act,
我们希望他们靠自己的努力站起来。这就是为什么1980年《难民法》的首要任务是经济自给自足。难民被期望尽快找到工作并摆脱政府支持。职业咨询是指导工作的一个关键部分。以前学到的工作技能有时是可以适应的。然而，在其他情况下，必须学习全新的工作，并必须建立培训项目。在《难民法》通过后的45年里，
making it to the U.S. as a refugee has become a significant feat. To start, you have to undergo several interviews with international and U.S. agencies who decide if you qualify. They ask a series of questions. Like, are you fleeing political persecution? Will you be killed if you return home? If the answer is yes, and you can prove it, then the U.S. government subjects you to a series of rigorous background checks and medical screenings.
作为难民来到美国已成为一项重大壮举。首先，你必须接受国际和美国机构的多次面试，他们决定你是否符合资格。他们会问一系列问题。比如，你是在逃避政治迫害吗？如果你回国会被杀吗？如果答案是肯定的，并且你能证明这一点，那么美国政府会让你接受一系列严格的背景调查和医疗筛查。
The process takes up to two years. If you're approved and you already have family in the U.S., you'll be sent to live near them. Otherwise, the State Department decides which relocation site to send you to. Historically, the U.S. has accepted more refugees than any other nation. But once people get here, we offer them little support. Places like Canada give newly arrived refugees up to a year of services and financial assistance. But the U.S. gives people just three months, and then they're on their own. When a refugee arrives in the U.S. to a place like Greeley, one of the first things that happens is that they're assigned a caseworker who teaches them the basics of life in America, like how to find an apartment, how to take the bus and buy growth.
这个过程需要长达两年。如果你获批并且在美国已经有亲属，你将被送往他们附近居住。否则，国务院决定将你送往哪个安置点。历史上，美国接受的难民比任何其他国家都多。但一旦人们来到这里，我们提供的支持很少。像加拿大这样的地方为新抵达的难民提供长达一年的服务和经济援助。但美国只给人们三个月的时间，然后他们就得靠自己了。当难民抵达美国像格里利这样的地方时，发生的第一件事就是他们被分配了一名个案工作者，教他们美国生活的基本知识，比如如何找公寓，如何乘公交车和购买杂货，
and how to see a doctor. But the most critical thing a newly arrived refugee needs to learn is how to get a job. I started as just what's called like a job developer. Back in 2008, early on in his career, John Tabor worked at a refugee resettlement agency in Illinois. I found John Thuwer researcher on refugee resettlement who worked with him at that same organization. They both thought they'd be helping refugees, but soon learned that wasn't necessarily true. In fact, years later, when I spoke with John over the phone, he felt a lot of remorse, which is why he was so honest and candid with me about what his work was actually like.
以及如何看医生。但新抵达的难民需要学习的最重要的事情是如何找到工作。我最初只是所谓的就业开发人员。早在2008年，在他职业生涯的早期，约翰·塔博尔在伊利诺伊州的一家难民安置机构工作。我找到了约翰·图尔，一位研究难民安置的研究员，他曾与他在同一组织工作。他们都以为自己在帮助难民，但很快发现事实并非一定如此。事实上，多年后，当我通过电话与约翰交谈时，他感到非常懊悔，这就是为什么他对我坦诚地讲述了他的工作实际上是什么样的。
There is only a very, very small amount of resettlement money that these families are allocated. You know, if they don't get a job pretty much immediately, they're unable to pay their bills. So, you know, within a few months, they'd be facing homelessness. You know, like literally, welcome to America. Now you're going to be evicted. At his job, John was up against the same clock as the refugees he was helping. He had to get everyone gainfully employed before their three-month safety net ran out. And he might have a caseload of 50 to 60 people.
这些家庭分配到的安置资金非常、非常少。你知道，如果他们不能几乎立即找到工作，他们就无法支付账单。所以，你知道，几个月内，他们就会面临无家可归。你知道，就像字面意思上的，欢迎来到美国。现在你要被驱逐了。在他的工作中，约翰和那些他正在帮助的难民一样，在与时间赛跑。他必须在三个月的安全网用完之前让每个人都获得有报酬的工作。他可能要处理50到60人的个案。
You know, did a little bit of sort of skill development, but frankly, we didn't really have a lot of time for that. It was mostly get their resume together, try to figure out what they did in the past. and get them into work as soon as possible. But it was rarely that straightforward. We're talking about some of the most vulnerable people on the planet. Many didn't have any skills that would translate to the modern American job context. Some had lived in refugee camps for their entire lives. They didn't have any work experience.
你知道，做了一点点技能开发，但坦率地说，我们真的没有太多时间。主要是整理他们的简历，试着弄清楚他们过去做了什么，并尽快让他们投入工作。但这很少那么简单。我们谈论的是地球上最脆弱的一些人。许多人没有任何可以转化为现代美国工作环境的技能。有些人一生都住在难民营里。他们没有任何工作经验。
You know, you couldn't put like sitting around the refugee camp or you couldn't put like tilling the field, you know. It just wouldn't translate. And so John and his fellow job developers connected the refugees with whatever employment options they could find. It's not like they were applying to some high-level management position. They were at entry-level meatpacking jobs. Meatpacking. Remember Mohamed, the Burmese refugee from the beginning of the story? This is exactly how he got his job.
你知道，你不能写“坐在难民营里”或者你不能写“耕地”，你知道。这根本转化不了。所以约翰和他的同事们将难民与他们能找到的任何就业选择联系起来。并不是说他们在申请什么高级管理职位。他们是在入门级的肉类加工工作。肉类加工。还记得故事开头那个缅甸难民穆罕默德吗？这正是他找到工作的方式。
A caseworker referred him to JBS. John remembers it was one of the most reliable choices because meatpacking plans. plants were always hiring and they paid better than most of the other options. With the high rates of injury and turnover, plants were constantly looking for new workers and the jobs didn't require any English or previous experience. There's one company, Tyson Foods. Like JBS, Tyson is also a massive American meatpacking company. Tyson would announce like eight positions or nine positions and you'd get, you know,
个案工作者把他推荐给了JBS。约翰记得这是最可靠的选择之一，因为肉类加工厂总是需要人，而且工资比大多数其他选择要好。由于高受伤率和高流动率，工厂一直在寻找新工人，而且这些工作不需要任何英语或先前的经验。有一家公司，泰森食品。像JBS一样，泰森也是一家大型美国肉类加工公司。泰森会宣布八个或九个职位，你会得到，你知道，
we would all show up with our refugees and, And it was a very, a very well-established feeder. He wasn't a humanitarian project for them. It was here as a group of workers that will be efficient and effective and, you know, we'll work faster and better than your American employees. And so that was the kind of relationships that we would form. So, like, we were selling a product, really. And as time went on, John noticed that the recruiters he was in touch with at Tyson
我们都会带着我们的难民出现，而且，这是一个非常、非常成熟的输送渠道。对他来说，这不是一个人道主义项目。这是一群高效且有效的工人，你知道，他们会比你的美国员工工作得更快、更好。所以这就是我们建立的那种关系。所以，就像，我们实际上是在推销一种产品。随着时间的推移，约翰注意到他联系的泰森招聘人员
became more specific about what type of worker they wanted? Not so subtly would say, you know, we give us Burmese. You know, they were just sort of, you know, these workers have worked out in the past. And there was this sort of tacit understanding was we should deliver them these workers. Like if we showed up with five or six, I'm just saying like Iraqis, let's say. Because, you know, Iraqis had personalities, you know, big personalities. They came from different culture. That we knew that wasn't going to satisfy their,
对他们想要的工人类型变得更加具体？他们会不那么含蓄地说，你知道，给我们缅甸人。你知道，他们只是那种，你知道，这些工人在过去表现得很好。而且有一种默契，就是我们应该给他们提供这些工人。就像如果我们带着五六个，我只是说，伊拉克人出现。因为，你知道，伊拉克人有个性，你知道，有个性。他们来自不同的文化。我们知道那不会满足他们的，
demands. And that's not something I'm particularly proud of, but it was just the realities we were facing. He says this part of the job kept him up at night. He and his team at the agency even tried to come up with alternatives. But nothing ever really worked. You know, it just, the American machine just swallowed him up. And there was never any breathing room. I mean, the margins are tiny in our system. After a few more years in this work, John left the field. but it taught him something about America's refugee resettlement program. The narrative that we're giving people these great opportunities, you know, like there's a dark side. The system is supposed to get refugees out of danger, but it then leaves them with little support.
需求。这不是我特别引以为豪的事情，但这只是我们面临的现实。他说这份工作的这一部分让他彻夜难眠。他和他在机构的团队甚至尝试过寻找替代方案。但没有任何办法真正奏效。你知道，这只是，美国机器吞噬了他们。而且从来没有任何喘息的空间。我的意思是，我们系统中的利润空间很小。在这项工作中又做了几年后，约翰离开了这个领域。但他教会了他关于美国难民安置项目的一些事情。我们给人们提供这些绝佳机会的叙事，你知道，就像有一个阴暗面。这个系统本应让难民脱离危险，但随后却让他们几乎得不到支持。
Many don't have language skills or a safety net. Compared to other immigrant groups, they're overrepresented in low-skilled work, they earn less, and are more likely to live in poverty. That's what makes them ideal recruits for meatpackers like JBS. With so few options, they take jobs most others won't. And even when the work leaves them injured, pushes them to work at impossible speeds, or exposes them to religious discrimination, many feel they have no choice but to stay.
许多人没有语言技能或安全网。与其他移民群体相比，他们在低技能工作中占比过高，收入更低，更有可能生活在贫困中。这就是他们成为像JBS这样的肉类加工商理想招募对象的原因。由于选择太少，他们接受了大多数其他人不会接受的工作。即使工作让他们受伤，迫使他们以不可能的速度工作，或者让他们遭受宗教歧视，许多人也觉得除了留下别无选择。
We reached out to JBS for this story, but they declined to comment. Back in Muhammad's home, he tells me a bit about what it would. like when he first came to Greeley. It was a shock to leave behind the hot, tropical climate of Burma. He remembers he saw snow here for the first time. What's something that Greeley doesn't have that you miss
我们联系了JBS寻求对此事的评论，但他们拒绝置评。回到穆罕默德的家中，他告诉我一些关于他刚来到格里利时的情景。离开缅甸炎热的热带气候是一个巨大的冲击。他记得他在这里第一次看到了雪。格里利有什么你从家乡缅甸带来的东西所没有的，
from your home country, Burma? I think he's going to have. He said Greeley didn't have the same vera. Yeah, so he's talking about the gardening. Oh. The gardening? He said Greeley didn't have the same verbal. variety of fruits and vegetables he was used to.
让你怀念的吗？我想他会有的。他说格里利没有同样的……是的，所以他在谈论园艺。哦。园艺？他说格里利没有他习惯的那种水果和蔬菜品种。
So he started a garden in the backyard. How did he grow? Redis, watermelon, pumpkin. When I met him, Muhammad had been off work for several weeks on disability with an injured hand. He showed me how when he tried to. To make a fist, some of the fingers wouldn't bend. It gets stuck like that? Yeah.
所以他在后院开辟了一个菜园。他种了什么？萝卜、西瓜、南瓜。当我见到他时，穆罕默德因为手部受伤已经休残疾假好几周了。他向我展示了当他试图握拳时，有些手指无法弯曲。它会卡在那里吗？是的。
Yeah. Just from the same gripping motion. Yeah. He had surgery a few years ago, but it still doesn't work like it used to. And I cannot fix. It's made a fist properly. And I cannot hold something as a firm way. So this is the problem.
是的。仅仅是因为同样的抓握动作。是的。他几年前做过手术，但它仍然不像以前那样好用了。我无法修复。它无法正确握拳。我无法以稳固的方式握住东西。所以这就是问题所在。
Still, he tells me he. he's eager to get back to work. When we spoke, his immediate family, including his wife and five kids, were still displaced and living in India. And he helped support about 20 members of his extended family as well. Yes, I want to go back as soon as possible because there's many kind of bills I have to pay. So I can't go because I don't get doctor's approval yet.
尽管如此，他告诉我他渴望回到工作中。当我们交谈时，他的直系亲属，包括他的妻子和五个孩子，仍然流离失所，住在印度。他还帮助供养了大约20名大家庭成员。是的，我想尽快回去，因为有很多账单要付。所以我不能去，因为我还没有得到医生的批准。
With this influx of refugees, the city of Greeley, was once again transformed. In 2007, just one year after the ice raids, the foreign-born population grew to about 13,000, a 76% increase from seven years earlier. In 2008, Greeley became an official refugee resettlement site. Now instead of moving to Greeley from a nearby city, a person could be brought there directly from a refugee camp, and inevitably, they'd be recruited for a job at JBS. It was a lot for a small city of 90,000. And just like before, it wasn't always pretty. A local mosque was shot at in broad daylight.
随着难民的涌入，格里利市再次发生了转变。2007年，即ICE突袭一年后，外国出生的人口增长到约13,000人，比七年前增加了76%。2008年，格里利成为官方的难民安置点。现在，一个人不再是从附近的城市搬到格里利，而是可以直接从难民营被带到那里，不可避免地，他们会被招募到JBS工作。对于一个9万人的小城市来说，这负担太重了。就像以前一样，情况并不总是美好的。当地的一座清真寺在光天化日之下遭到枪击。
There was a small anti-Sharia law protest. In the lens of history, that was not long after 9-11. Here's James Horan again from the Refugee Resettlement Agency. And so I think there was a lot of focus on Islam. And what does it mean that now there is an Islamic community in my community? James spent a lot of time holding community meetings where people could come to ask questions. He remembers he had to dispel a lot of the same myths that persist today. Another thing I would talk to people a lot about is the security clearances that refugees go through.
发生了一场小规模的反伊斯兰教法抗议活动。从历史的角度来看，那是在9/11事件后不久。这是来自难民安置机构的詹姆斯·霍兰。所以我认为人们非常关注伊斯兰教。现在我的社区里有一个伊斯兰社区，这意味着什么？詹姆斯花了很多时间举行社区会议，人们可以在会上提问。他记得他不得不消除许多今天仍然存在的同样的神话。我经常和人们谈论的另一件事是难民通过的安全审查。
Because that was another question. Is this a public safety issue? But with time, Greeley, once again, adjust it. Today, there's a strong network of support services like food pantries and driving courses. There are free English classes and GEDC. courses taught in the evenings at the local library. The public schools have a successful ESL program. And then there's the Immigrant and Refugee Center of Northern Colorado, which helps refugees do everything from interpret their mail to apply for citizenship.
因为那是另一个问题。这是一个公共安全问题吗？但随着时间的推移，格里利再次适应了。今天，这里有强大的支持服务网络，如食品分发处和驾驶课程。当地图书馆在晚上提供免费英语课程和GED课程。公立学校有成功的ESL项目。还有北科罗拉多移民和难民中心，它帮助难民做从翻译邮件到申请公民身份的所有事情。
Yeah, I'm just helping him pay the bill. I think this is the toll bill that he needs help paying. So this is like a regular. that we do here. This is Karim Abdulmanaf, who works at the center. And why is that? Just because it's all in English? Yeah, sometimes it's all because it's all in English.
是的，我只是在帮他付账单。我想这是他需要帮助支付的账单。所以这就像我们在这里做的常规工作。这是卡里姆·阿卜杜勒马纳夫，他在中心工作。为什么会这样？只是因为全是英文吗？是的，有时完全是因为全是英文。
And at the times, they don't know how to navigate all those websites and everything. So that's one of the reasons they come here. Kareem arrived in Greeley about eight years ago. He and his family became refugees after facing persecution in their home country of Burma. He speaks Rohingya and helps other Rohingya refugees. translate things from English, like they're phone bills and big statements. So you're kind of able to be the
而且有时候，他们不知道如何浏览所有这些网站等等。所以这就是他们来这里的原因之一。卡里姆大约八年前来到格里利。他和他的家人在缅甸家乡遭受迫害后成为了难民。他讲罗兴亚语，并帮助其他罗兴亚难民翻译英语内容，比如他们的电话账单和银行对账单。所以你能够成为
helping hand that you didn't really have. Yes, and I'm glad that I can help the community to give them back. Because I know how it feels to be lost in a new place. Kareem worked at JBS for two years,
你当时并没有真正得到的帮助之手。是的，我很高兴我能帮助社区回馈他们。因为我知道在一个陌生的地方感到迷茫是什么感觉。卡里姆在JBS工作了两年，
and so did his four older brothers when they were first resettled in Greeley. It was and still is the primary job in the area that doesn't require English or any previous experience. I wouldn't say JBS is a long-term job, but for some of the families, they are planning to just do JBS for as long as they can. They have to do it because they have no other options here in the GRILE. And recently, there's been yet another new wave of arrivals, the many thousands of Haitians and Venezuelans who came to the U.S. on temporary protected status.
他的四个哥哥在刚被安置到格里利时也一样。它过去是，现在仍然是该地区不需要英语或任何先前经验的主要工作。我不会说JBS是一份长期工作，但对于一些家庭来说，他们计划只要能做就一直做下去。他们必须这样做，因为他们在格里利没有其他选择。最近，又出现了一波新的抵达者，成千上万的海地人和委内瑞拉人以临时保护身份（TPS）来到美国。
TPS allows people from certain countries to stay and work here if it's too dangerous to go back home. What community do you primarily work with? Haitian community. This is Dree. He originally came to Greeley from New Jersey because he heard about the work available at JBS. But after a few weeks, he quit. It was overwhelming, a lot of pressure. especially from the management staff.
TPS允许来自某些国家的人如果回国太危险，可以留在这里工作。你主要与哪个社区合作？海地社区。这是德里。他最初从新泽西州来到格里利，因为他听说JBS有工作机会。但几周后，他辞职了。这太令人不知所措了，压力很大。特别是来自管理人员的压力。
They're trying to get stuff done like, you know, record time. So it's kind of challenging for your body and your man's hole. Then he showed up at this refugee and immigration center with a friend and was quickly offered a job because he speaks English and Haitian Creole fluently. Just like Kareem, he helps Haitians navigate life in Greeley. But the day we met, things got a lot more complicated. The Trump administration canceled, temporary. protected status for Venezuelans.
他们试图在创纪录的时间内完成工作。所以这对你的身体和心理来说都是一种挑战。然后他和朋友出现在这个难民和移民中心，因为他能流利地说英语和海地克里奥尔语，很快就得到了一份工作。就像卡里姆一样，他帮助海地人适应格里利的生活。但我们见面的那天，事情变得复杂多了。特朗普政府取消了委内瑞拉人的临时保护身份。
Haitians with protected status would be next. The Supreme Court just canceled the TPS for Venezuelans now. Like, we're talking about like 300,000 people. And that just happened. Yes. Probably going to cancel for Haitians. Do you think you'll get a lot of people in here today asking about that? The TPS, the fact that the new just came out, like minutes ago, for sure next week,
拥有受保护身份的海地人将是下一个。最高法院刚刚取消了委内瑞拉人的临时保护身份（TPS）。我们谈论的是大约30万人。这刚刚发生。是的。很可能会取消海地人的身份。你认为今天会有很多人来这里询问这件事吗？关于TPS，关于刚刚发布的消息，就在几分钟前，下周肯定会，
it's going to be like overwhelming for them, like to come and ask you a question, what can I do, what can I do, what would be the next step. The refugee program as we know it, the one created in the 1980s, is on pause indefinitely. The flow of people like Mohammed, Karim, and Dree, has all but stopped, which raises the same question the industry has faced for generations.
这对他们来说将是压倒性的，他们会来问你，我该怎么办，我该怎么办，下一步该怎么做。我们所知的难民计划，即1980年代创建的那个计划，目前处于无限期暂停状态。像穆罕默德、卡里姆和德里这样的人流几乎已经停止，这提出了该行业几代人以来一直面临的同样问题。
Where will the workers come from? If I were the CEO of a big company like JBS, I might be wringing my hands right about now. Of all U.S. industries, meatpacking has the fifth highest concentration of refugee workers. And more broadly, about 40% of meatpacking workers are foreign-born. I think there's definitely an economic conversation to be had. And I think employers will probably be the drivers of that. That's James Horan again. It's just going to be a math issue.
工人从哪里来？如果我是像JBS这样大公司的首席执行官，我现在可能会感到非常焦虑。在美国所有行业中，肉类加工业的难民工人比例排名第五。更广泛地说，大约40%的肉类加工工人是外国出生的。我认为绝对有必要进行一场关于经济的对话。而且我认为雇主可能会成为推动者。这是詹姆斯·霍兰再次提到的。这终究会是一个数学问题。
right? I think when you're an employer and you have a workforce need and you have a certain number of jobs open and you don't have people to draw on to fill those jobs, you are limited. As a country, we're once again in a fiercely anti-immigrant climate. And while every country needs a fair immigration system, we can't deny that the populations we're targeting play an essential role in our economy. They don't just fill jobs. They feel hard. They feel hard. dangerous jobs, the ones that most people will avoid if they have the choice. When people are deported in droves, it leaves a vacuum. When refugees aren't allowed to come, it leaves a vacuum. And when there's no one left to slaughter our cows, we're reminded of a truth, Upton Sinclair tried to tell us in the jungle. This country depends on vulnerable people to do its dirtiest, most grueling work.
对吧？我认为当你是一名雇主，有劳动力需求，有一定数量的职位空缺，却没有足够的人手来填补这些职位时，你就会受到限制。作为一个国家，我们再次处于一种极其反移民的氛围中。虽然每个国家都需要一个公平的移民制度，但我们不能否认，我们所针对的群体在我们的经济中发挥着至关重要的作用。他们不仅仅是填补职位。他们填补的是艰苦、危险的工作，是大多数人在有选择的情况下会避开的工作。当人们被大规模驱逐出境时，就会留下真空。当难民不被允许进入时，就会留下真空。当没有人来屠宰我们的牛时，我们就会想起厄普顿·辛克莱在《屠场》中试图告诉我们的真理。这个国家依赖弱势群体来从事最肮脏、最艰苦的工作。
We've just never wanted to see it. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Esther Honig and was produced and edited by Delaney Hall, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford. Fact-checking by Naomi Barr. This story was reported in collaboration with Fern, the Food and Environmental Reporting Network, and with funding from the 11th Hour Food and Farming Fellowship at UC Berkeley.
我们只是从来不想看到这一点。《99% Invisible》本周由埃丝特·霍尼格报道，由德莱尼·霍尔制作和编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德创作。事实核查由娜奥米·巴尔完成。本报道是与食品与环境报道网络（Fern）合作完成的，并获得了加州大学伯克利分校第11小时食品与农业奖学金的资助。
thanks this week to Colin Cannon, Ted Genoese, and Brent Cunningham. Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rights of the team includes Chris Baroube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lajman, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora, building in beautiful uptown oakland california you can find us on all the usual social media
感谢本周的科林·坎农、泰德·热诺斯和布伦特·坎宁安。凯西·图也是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉杰曼、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，以及我，罗曼·马斯。99% Invisible的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Serious XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的潘多拉大楼，你可以在所有常见的社交媒体上找到我们
sites as well as our own discord server there's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99 p i at 99 p i dot org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器，那里有一个链接，还有99% Invisible的每一集往期节目，网址是99pi.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。